And let's move on to
something a little bit more
exciting like an
app with a plot.
So this application
here is pretty similar,
but now, when I
change this slider,
it's going to change, I think,
the number of bins that go
into computing this histogram.
So you can see as I
increase the number of bins,
this histogram is going to
have more stagger to it.
So yeah, this one has a slightly
more complex user interface.
And notice as I make
the window wider,
this actually looks a little
bit more like a sidebar
than it does an input panel
or something like that.
So this sort of functionality is
provided by this layout sidebar
from the UI subpackage.
So with the layout
sidebar, it really
wants a sidebar panel
and a main panel.
And so on the
lefthand side here,
I have the slider,
similar to what
we had before, another
output text verbatim
on the righthand side,
and the main panel
and then a plot underneath that.
And this example starts to
introduce some reactivity
concepts.
So with this app's
reactive.calc,
this is a decorator for
defining a calculation that
depends on some input
values and then returns
another value from some
combination of input values.
So this is overly
simplistic example
that just reads
the slider value,
and then multiplies
it by two, and gives
this reactive
calculation a name of R.
So once I have this
function defined
as a reactive
calculation, then I
can read it just like I
would read an input value
inside of another
reactive context,
like this rendered text output.
So this is-- for all
practical purposes,
this is essentially the same
as just putting this expression
into the read of R, but for
more sophisticated reactive web
applications, this is a
really useful construct
for encapsulating a chunk
of a reactive calculation.
Whether it's performing
a data summary
or computing a model
from some data,
it's always a good
idea to put those steps
into reactive calculations.
Basically, it gives
Shiny more information
to do less work when it
makes sense to do less work.
So if you have a big-- you
can define a big reactive
chain with several calculations
that depend on each other
and if one of those
calculations gets
invalidated because the
value is out of date
for whatever reason,
Shiny knows to not go back
all the way to the top of that
graph and recompute everything.
It can just say I just need to
do the last two calculations
and then knows to do less
work when it makes sense to.
That is reactive
calculations in a nutshell.
And then to start showing
you some different variations
on rendering different types
of objects into UI, here's
an at.render plot.
And these decorators
can actually
be used without parentheses
or with parentheses.
You can call it a function.
And that's particularly
useful for something
like render plot, which
has additional arguments
that you can specify some
alt text to put on this image
to make it more accessible.
Then you use it just like
how you would a render text.
You define a function, and
you can give this function
a name, which should match
an ID in the user interface.
And then inside of this
function definition,
I can do something like
use that Matplotlib
to create a histogram
where the number of bins
in this histogram comes from
the value of the slider.
At least currently, the
way render plot works,
you're going to want to always
return a Matplotlib object.
And then we'll
know how to render
that object into an image.
I do also want to mention this
render plot has the ability
to understand more than
just Matplotlib objects,
and I've actually whipped
up this example app
to demonstrate that.
So I've at least laid out
a few different packages
here, but this is not--
render plot is not limited
to just these packages.
Essentially, any package that
builds on Matplotlib or pill
will be supported
through render plot.
A lot of the-- what a lot
of these packages will do
will essentially build
on that Matplotlib,
like Plotnine, which actually
gives more like a ggplot2 type
interface to creating graphics.
And they'll essentially
subclass a Matplotlib object,
meaning they are a special
form of a Matplotlib object.
So as long as your
object subclasses
Matplotlib in some
way, render plot
should be able to handle it.
So here's a Plotnine graph
in the Shiny application
I've programmed to allow
you to change x variable, y
variable, and color.
We also support Seaborn.
You might be familiar with
Pandas' plotting interface,
where you can essentially,
from your data frame object,
call .plot on that
data frame object.
And that will return, I think
in every case, a Matplotlib
object.
So you can just basically call
.plot and return that value,
and render plot
should handle that.
There's also Hollowvies,
which supports all different--
it also has interactive
visualization capabilities,
but you can also use
Matplotlib with Hollowvies.
xarray and geopandas, so
lots of different packages
out there that luckily
build on top of Matplotlib,
and you can all use
with render plot.
So just to give you a quick
idea of what I mean there,
so this is actually the source
code for that application that
were are looking at.
So here's a render
plot with Seaborn
that's creating the scatterplot
with the kernel density
estimate on top of it.
Plotnine was the more
ggplot2-like interface here,
where I'm reading like an
x input value and a y input
value.
So whenever those
change, Shiny will know
to re-execute this function.
As I mentioned with
pandas, there's a dot plot.
So you can call that and
return whatever that returns.
Hollowviews, it's a little
bit less straightforward.
There's this render function
from Hollowviews that
takes in a back end argument.
So as long as you specify
I want to use Matplotlib,
then you can use it
with render plot.
xarray is similar to
pandas in the sense
that it has like a
similar dot plot-ike
interface from its
special data structure.
And that also returns
Matplotlib objects.
Again, geopandas,
a lot like pandas,
where you can just call .plot.
And then missingno, I think,
also returns Matplotlib object,
this matrix function here.